hey what's up guys my name is the
cheddar waving my arms around welcome
back to my say plus plus series today
we're going to talk all about implicit
construction C++ implicit conversions as
well as what the explicit keyword
actually means so implicit conversion
plus it concern what am I talking about
implicit means kind of without you
explicitly telling it what to do so it
kind of automatic that's what that work
kind of means in this context and what's
the bus bus is actually allowed to do
what the compiler is allowed to do is
perform one implicit conversion on your
code because if I kind of start using
one data type as another and a
conversion between the two exists C++
will actually implicitly perform that
conversion without you having to cast it
or anything like that
whoever video and casting very soon
casting is what we do to kind of convert
from one data type to another so this is
best shown with an example so let's take
a look I'm going to write a class here
it's going to be called entity it's
going to have a private string name you
guys know the drill I've done this
before I'm also going to add an age to
this will create an NC constructor which
takes in a name I write Const St string
reference name Palestine name to name
here also create another constructor
which takes in an age I'll sign name
here to be unknown an age to be age I
should definitely also assign age over
here we'll set age to be negative one
meaning that it's invalid basically no
age was supplied okay nice so we have
two constructors here which are pretty
simple
so the normal way that you would
probably create these objects is by
writing something like entity a can
maybe give you a name like sugar and GB
maybe giving this one in agents 222
that's actually how old I am for those
of you wondering because I get that
question a lot for some reason and you
would kind of go about your day and not
think twice and this looks pretty simple
maybe if you want to use equals you
would write your code like this and it
kind of looks normal this is how most
people use objects and how much people
instantiate objects but what you can do
which a lot of people don't know is just
basically say that n CA is equal to
Turner or NTP is
equal to 22 now this is a little bit
weird because well first of all you
can't do this in other languages like
Java or C sharp but second of all entity
B equals 22
what is interesting integer I mean North
is got string and it's got a name but I
can assign 22 what's going on here this
is called implicit conversion or illicit
construction it's implicitly converting
that 22 into an axiom constructing an
entity out of it because there's a
constructor fantasy which takes in an
integer age right and there's a
constructor fantasy which takes in a
name check another example where you
might say this is maybe you have a print
st function which takes in an entity and
then maybe does some cool printing stuff
what you can actually do here is call
that function with 22 right and that
looks weird because we'll hang on a
minute
we don't have an overload for print and
T which takes in an integer or something
like that we've just got one that takes
in an entity but remember as far as c++
is concerned 22 can be converted into an
entity because you can call this
constructor and suddenly from 22 which
is the only parameter you've made an
entity now watch what happens when I try
and call this print entity function with
Cherno you would kind of assume it to
work right because this did no it
doesn't work and the reason it didn't
work is because this churner string
isn't actually an STD string it is a
char array it's a Const our array of
seven characters we've got shown on and
then an old termination character if you
guys don't know how strings work link up
their link in the description below
thanks everywhere go check that video
out a very very useful stuff so in order
for this to work C++ would actually have
to do two conversions one from a Const
RA into a string and then one from a
string to an entity and it's only
allowed to do one implicit conversion so
for this to work we would have to either
wrap this inside a constructor like this
the string and suddenly this works fine
or we could even wrap it just in an
entity and that would work as well
because in this case it would be
implicitly converting this string into a
string into an STD string into a
standard string and then that will be
pushed into the HD constructor and
constructor available okay cool that's
impressive construction pretty cool
stuff can help simplify your code a lot
personally I try to avoid it as much as
possible except for some some cases when
you're kind of assigning it can get it
can kind of just simply oh so you're not
wrapping it with constructors all the
time but in general I wouldn't be
assigning this entity b22 like this I
personally would write code like this
instead because in my opinion it just
looks a bit more clear now let's talk
about what the explicit keyword is
because it's very very relevant to this
explicit disables the simplistic analogy
the explicit keyword is something that
you put in front of a constructor and if
you write an explicit constructor it
means that no no no no no implicit
conversions this constructor must
explicitly be called if you want to
construct this entity object with an
integer for example so let's go back to
having this implicit conversion here if
I go up here and I change this int age
constructor to be explicit by sticking
explicit out the front you'll see that
these birds suddenly fail I cannot do
that anymore if I want to do this I need
to either write code like that
or explicitly cast it to an entity by
doing this we'll talk about passing in
another video it'll be a link up there
and in description below as well all we
can of course just call that entity
constructor like this as well okay so
those are kind of our options but we can
no longer just implicitly call code like
this and expect it to work it's not
going to happen and of course if we
write explicit for this constructor
which takes in string then of course
this is going to fail as well not this
one just yet because we are still of
course actually calling the entity
constructor but everything else that is
implicit like this one fails and that is
really the only function of that
explicit keyword it's for when you want
your constructors to be explicitly
called instead of allowing the sibyl's
compiler to implicitly convert any
integer into entity by just basically
calling this constructor every time you
try and do that okay so that's what
implicit is that's what explicit is
hopefully this plays some stuff up as
for when you want to use this I use
explicit sometimes for things like math
libraries if I really don't want to be
comparing numbers to vectors
time and I want to just ensure that my
code is as safe as possible
honestly I don't find myself using it
too often when you're writing low-level
rappers or things like that it can come
in handy and can prevent you from
accidentally casting things and causing
you the performance issues or buzz will
kind of maybe talk about specific
examples in the future if we run into
them but it's one of those things that
you probably don't need to worry about
too much just be aware of this keyword
and what it can do for you and the big
the big take away I think from this
video is just be aware that implicit
construction exists hope you guys enjoy
this video if you did you hit that like
button you can also help support this
series and make it even better by going
to patreon home for such the channel but
they don't reduce support the series you
do get some pretty cool rewards such as
being able to see these exits early
basically as soon as I'm done editing
them as well as contribute to the
discussion of what goes into these
videos in the future if there's
something in this video that you didn't
understand you can leave a comment below
and I'll try and reply to as many as I
can but I also have a discourse above
link in the description below in which
you could talk about this kind of stuff
with with a handful of people I think
there's like 200 people in the 700 race
that's pretty cool definitely join up
their link in description below and I'll
see you guys in the next video goodbye
[Music]
[Music]